[Musique]
on le sait bernard montiel adore donner
des interviews mais ce qu'il aime par
dessus tout c'est balance est un vrai
régal pour les journalistes qui
l'interrogent mais aussi pour les
auditeurs qui n'aura pas une miette
invité hier de sud radio perdre 1
mondial n'a pas fait mentir sa
réputation de grande gueule de la télé
derrière son attitude de monde à sa
baisse de star de la chanson des années
bernard n'a pas hésité à dire ce qu'il
pensait de l'univers impitoyable du
petit écran
cinq métiers de deux salles ou pas bien
sur pied deux [ __ ]
il faut dire que dans sa carrière
bernard montiel a connu à plusieurs
reprises des moments difficiles
notamment lorsqu'il s'est fait licencier
du jour au lendemain de tf1 avait une
grande traversée du désert pas un grand
nom a duré trois mois tf1 alors la
phrase de bernard montiel la télé est un
métier êtes vous d'accord
bon alors ouais je pourrais le redire si
vous voulez maintenant la raison mais
que c'est un métier de pitch matériaux
on reste courtois o tu t'es cru ou alors
est ce qu est ce que l'armée sans regret
est-ce que ce métier est un métier alors
voilà on peut voir la question normal
êtes vous d'accord avec bernard montiel
qui dit que c'est un métier difficile
fin cette amitié on peut pas avoir
confiance ça que ça veut dire
c'est là qu'il veut dire bah oui c'est
ça qui veut dire oui nom vous dit non
mais maintenant j'en mets l'oeil du
n'importe quoi ça fait partie du métier
[Rires]
mon avis oui mais vous non mais c'est
pas ça mais moi aussi alors dans ce cas
là je vais demander à n'importe qui et
non mais c'est pas un métier de [ __ ]
comme y disent non excusez moi je
réponds sans expression c mais normaux
alors alors croit plus en l'amour
d'accord c'est pour ça qu'elle me choque
qui est des rivalités que parfois on
soit en concurrence pour une place mais
dire ça ça voudrait dire qu'il ya des
félonie des trahisons passé vous rêvez
we enter le monde toi y avait c'est vrai
nathalie défonce le nom mais moi je
pensais par rapport
c'est de la politique de de tout cela je
suis pas dans ça reste deux minutes
qu'est ce qui se passe on a plein d'amis
tout le monde nous aimer jouer on est on
est viré
on est on est abandonné et ses saveurs
d'asie c'est pas il n'a pas d'amis déjà
mais c'est vrai que par rapport des
femmes alors voilà c'est comme partout 6
heures et eiffage et les boulangers
pâtissiers boulangers n'est pas ton
n'est pas dupe des gens qui nous
entourent ont en ce qu'il tende la main
et ce qu'ils ne tenteront pas la main on
le sait et on sait très bien que le jour
où la traversée du désert aride réel
fillon ça se confirme à pas et
entreprises aux liquidations jolie
patrick sébastien aussi bien sûr alors
jean ton nom puis il faut le dire en
télé il ya beaucoup de gens médiocres
parce que c'est un milieu qui
contrairement à ce que si on a des
joueurs qui sont sur le plateau c'est
pas sympa contrairement à ce qu'on croit
à la télé c'est ouvert à beaucoup de
gens c'est ouvert ya plein de gens qui
veulent bosser en télé ferait sûrement
et donc franchement non je vous le dis
quand on ya plein de gens ici sont
faciles pour sartre en seine-et-marne
avec c'est plutôt fermé il céder en
tombe bien sûr le talent hanté les gens
médiocres et donc il ya beaucoup de gens
qui s'improvisent animateur producteur
réalisateur j'ai fait ça de vrai ces
gens là ils sont prêts à tout pour
garder leur place quitte à faire des
sales coups donc la réponse est oui sur
des faits des frais en début d'été
jarnac passé là oui je pense que ton de
cette étape je suis évidemment ces cas
le moins d'expérience un peu dans le
showbiz avec motel avec mon nom mais je
voulais dire que le peu temps en tout
cas que j'ai passé dans ce milieu là bas
j'ai en fait grâce à mon expérience
personnelle j'ai eu des mauvaises
expériences qui me permettent de dire
que oui effectivement c'est pas voilà
alors mon retour au score
vous avez fait quoi des vannes ouest a
devancé veulent à nouveau les stars
n'étaient pas nés c'est bon et au nombre
de douze heures de colle soit calme et
toi non mais du coup c'est vrai que j'ai
eu une expérience qu'est ce qui s'est
passé il ya eu énormément de choses mais
pas qu'une seule s'est bougé rien dit
non mais oui c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
d'ailleurs que vous serrez comme on
m'avait proposé le fait d'être
chroniqueuse
je me souviens j'étais à 6 à la place de
thomas m'avait proposé ça j'ai pas du
tout cru ça c'est vrai j'ai pas du tout
pris je me suis dit oui encore une
promesse dans l'île a pas loyale a plein
qui n'ont pas cru en théorie horizon
culture et
attendez moi tu annonces des nouveaux et
aux chroniqueurs tous les jours un ado
surcroît ça passe ça oui crocodile
dundee elle a parlé l'autre paire
nicolas là aujourd'hui
pour l'instant on n'est pas payé c'est
vrai par giuly alors il va se passera
tort non mais effectivement c'est un
métier qui est violent et ingrat et vous
savez très bien que vous êtes animateur
télé quand ça s'arrête le lendemain tout
s'arrête le thé les sourires ne sonnent
plus et les gens ne vous reconnaissent
même plus loin en russie est terrible
c'est vrai mais c'est patrick savatier
qu'il raconte est très bien à l'époque
est à dire que on a besoin d'être de
plus en plus exposés pour que les gens
pensent à vous et dès que vous n'êtes
plus exposés les jours gras d'exposer
enfin comme vous exploser c'est vrai ça
n'en fait pas pour autant un métier oui
ça c'est pas de saint-pardon moi j'ai
vécu une traversée du désert et tout le
monde vous a craché à la gueule mais
naïve a réussi ou le cerf avait
absolument pas et je vais pas aussi
fonction de comment vous vous comportez
que vous si personne ne vous tend la
main quand ça va pas bien c'est que vous
êtes vous même temps apporter sa
médaille ils vont vous jeter des pierres
je les ai vus jeté des pierres comme ça
à john et de bellaïd arrêté oui alors
oui et sans forcément parler de l'après
la télé c'est un milieu qui fait rêver
c'est un milieu dont qui est très
convoité et ribes et jaloux de partout
donc il ya des gens qui aiment le disait
qu'ils sont prêts à tout pour prendre
votre place ou pour c'est pas mieux
talbi cse le mieux placé parce que lui
sa carrière à l'as fait çà çà çà çà et
là il est au top à voile et au top après
des mois pour rejoindre bernard c'est un
métier où il ya pas mal de coups de [ __ ]
mais le toit s'est on pas que son âme
était de [ __ ] est ce que j'aime pas
cette idée qu'il ya que des salopards et
les [ __ ] ont fait de belles
rencontres et ont fait de belles
rencontres entre les visions et des
enfants mais daté quoi vos belles
rencontres va parler maintenant et vous
par exemple un maire mais moi j'ai été
trés gilbert devrait au contraire sur m6
j'étais très bien avec le patron de tf1
l'époque avec d'enjeux pas obligés de
quitter un mec très hâte orient donc il
ya des gens ça va très bien c'est
toujours avec exceptionnelle avec
incroyable et pour le coup il m'a pas vu
il m'a pas pour y aller dans l'eau donc
il ya des gens il ya des coups de [ __ ]
mais moi j'ai fait des belles rencontres
voilà et j'en fais tous les jours des
rencontres
honnêtement non mais le mot un peu
grossier c'est qu'ils me lui m'avait
lancé en disant il ya c'est une bande de
[ __ ] et moizini non c'est une bande
de [ __ ] voilà d'accord
dans la surenchère c'est ça en fait un
homme est arrêté avec thomas question
soit ça moi je rejoins peu ce que dit
valérie en dessous c'est le monde
demandait un peu dur c'est pas le monde
de la télé spécialement qui est un monde
de plus que le monde est un peu dure et
des fois il ya des coups durs quels que
soient les domaines mais mais je pense
qu'il faut pas être si négatif que ça
voilà il ya des mauvaises personnes mais
c'est partout comme ça mais mais il ya
de belles rencontres comme l'a dit
benjamin l'instant loin de réduire les
choses monde de [ __ ] non non il ya des
belles choses qui se font en télé selon
thomas ce soir mais c'est une belle
chose pour la france qu'elle est quel
est le mot qui qualifie touche pas à mon
poste vous citez en permanence le mot
famille est ici c'est pas un lieu de
fidélité d'amitié il n'y a pas de coups
d'autres pour raconter des balivernes